chocolate is an aphrodisiac there's a
reason you give your lover chocolate on
Valentine's Day because it's time to
play do you understand you
feed them chocolate and then you have
sex in the parking lot you have sex in
the parking lot
you have sex in the parking lot
Pizza does not do that you eat pizza and
you are burping you are far
is over dude it's over you have never
had sexy time after Pizza Pizza is not a
romantic food pizza is not a romantic
food to eat
[Music]
first of all what is a mild sexual
stimulant it's not gonna burst your
boner through your shorts you know what
do you want a hard sexual stimulant in
chocolate